Wendy gagnant donc moi je concours dans
la catégorie j'avais mis création
d'emploi mais je crois que c'est pas la
bonne catégorie donc je suis plutôt dans
l'insertion en fait je suis maquilleuse
donc depuis un an et demi donc je
travaille pour un gros groupe de
parfumerie en étant prestataire de
service donc en fait le maquillage bon
tout le monde connaît mais souvent c'est
assimilé à l'esthétique donc je suis pas
esthéticienne je suis vraiment
spécialisée dans le maquillage c'est
pour sublimer en fait les beautés
réunionnaises de n'importe quel type
donc ça peut être un homme une femme
j'ai déjà maquillé des hommes des femmes
voilà ça peut être dans le la beauté ça
peut être pour une pub ça peut être pour
un mariage ça peut être voilà donc
on va dire toutes sortes de prestations
qui peut exister où on a besoin de
d'être maquillée derrière voilà ça peut
aider une personne à se voilà à se
sentir mieux dans sa peau ça peut aider
des personnes à camoufler des petits des
petits défauts et moi je suis là voilà
pour je suis maquilleuse itinérante donc
je fais toute l'île
voilà après j'aime mon métier j'aime
tout ce qui touche à la création donc on
voit on voit pas tous les jours les
mêmes mises visages on va pas tous les
jours les mêmes gens donc moi c'est ce
que j'aime dans mon métier et j'avais
envie de faire partager ça en fait il
faut dire que je suis pas du tout issue
de ce milieu là à la base moi j'ai un
ESS de communication option journaliste
donc il y a pas du tout le lien avec
l'esthétique j'ai eu l'opportunité en
fait de rencontrer le grand patron d'une
parfumerie et en fait il m'a il m'a
débauché il m'a dit voilà est-ce que
vous voulez être notre maquilleuse
officiel
pour ce groupe là donc j'ai dit oui mais
en sachant que voilà je voulais pas être
employé je voulais vraiment être à mon
compte et du coup il a accepté mes
conditions et à côté je peux faire quand
même d'autres choses d'autres voilà je
suis pas que liée à ce groupe là je suis
vraiment pour moi et c'est ce qui me
plaît d'être libre en fait voilà
bonjour je me présente paton Olivier
j'habite à Saint-André donc ça fait un
an et un mois que j'ai créé mon
entreprise c'est service à la personne
donc ménage et repassage à domicile donc
le ménage c'est beaucoup à la vapeur et
des huiles essentielles et du vinaigre
blanc donc c'est un ménage écologique je
ramène tout mon matériel chez la
personne donc que ce soit ma machine
quoi aspirer et qui nettoie en même
temps à la vapeur qui nettoie aussi les
baies vitrées les sanitaires les canapés
et les lits on va dire ça fait 10 ans
que je suis dans la restauration en
métropole je suis arrivé ici et j'ai on
va dire pendant les 10 ans la
restauration je faisais le repassage
pour mes clients on va dire des clients
à saisis on va dire des stars américains
donc je faisais le repassage et aussi un
peu les nettoyage de leur chambre donc
même si j'étais on va dire maître
d'hôtel on faisait un peu tout dans
l'hôtel donc voilà c'est une passion le
ménage cuisine et un passage c'est une
passion que voilà que chez depuis
longtemps et j'ai dit pourquoi pas
pourquoi les autres ils réussissent
pourquoi pas moi donc je me suis lancé
et pour l'instant ça marche on est là
pour voilà dire faire un petit peu de
pub on va dire c'est un petit plus c'est
un tremplin à passer et on va dire c'est
que grâce à vous si on peut avoir pour
des clients tu as la mieux créer des
emplois surtout avec la crise en ce
moment si c'est possible créer des
emplois et grandir la société
bonjour je m'appelle Christine schillais
je représente un club sur le département
de La Réunion depuis un an maintenant
qui s'appelle l'invitation le club
existe en métropole depuis 3 ans le
concept est de créer des partenariats
avec des établissements hôteliers
restaurateurs loisirs bien-être et par
la suite de pouvoir faire bénéficier de
ces offres aux membres donc qui ont la
carte l'invitation alors la carte
l'invitation elle est valable 12 mois de
datadat elle est nominative et
l'avantage c'est qu'elle est valable
dans les DOM-TOM et en France
métropolitaine le petit plus c'est que
le concept se développe aussi en
Belgique au Luxembourg et bientôt en
Espagne ce qui permettra d'avoir un côté
international donc à mon niveau ce
serait de relancer un tout petit peu
comme je dis à mon niveau
l'économie touristique je suis dans la
phase de création un site local qui
mettra donc en avant ces établissements
un petit livret qui mettra aussi en
avant donc sur un support papier nos
partenaires et vraiment de diffuser un
maximum le concept l'invitation alors la
grosse différence c'est qu'avec une
seule carte je peux voyager partout et
je peux bénéficier d'offres en acheter à
nous faire c'est le principe
avec les différents concurrents je ne
pense pas que ce soit le cas je sais que
si je vais en métropole demain dans tel
ou telle région je regarde sur leur site
internet le site internet qui est
national
voilà je réserve auprès d'un hôtel ou
d'un restaurant c'est le petit plus je
pense de du concept de l'invitation